i dramatically changed my life so i i
wonder when a
cormier says drama he can he's never
going to change and everybody i've
interviewed from the ufc side i've
talked to i've always asked who do you
think can one day replace dana white
i gotta tell you unanimously do you
think conor could do it no do you think
joe could do joe wouldn't want to do you
think this
almost everybody i've asked who could
replace dana's job is cormier i'm
telling you that's what a lot of people
maybe you disagree with that no i think
dc can't yeah sure so so they say dc so
i ask why
because dana is straight up and he'll
tell you your flaws you screwed up like
dana will see on the camera and say
what the hell was he doing throwing
something on the on the bus what are you
doing like what were you thinking or
what are you thinking jumping out or in
that one fight where khabib was like
give me the belt i want my belt let me
tell you something if i give you the
belt right now here's what i think is
going to happen this place going to go
crazy shit's going to get ugly i'm going
to give it to you later i can handle it
i'm not giving you the both like you
those are not easy conversations to have
like the average person will be like all
right here you go let me give you the
belt no the guy sticks and then for dc
to say
a person doesn't make the same mistake
over and over and over and over and over
again right that's a tough thing to tell
somebody yeah you know that's a very
tough thing to say somebody so
does a dc
believe that
you know
and then i see a story with me the
change
my dad and i have the biggest debates
all the time here's my dad and his
biggest debate i would have my friends
come over and say that i think this
guy's going to make a very big impact on
his life so no he's not i said what are
you talking about you know what he would
say
he would say look how short he is look
what he weighs he said this can't even
discipline his diet you think he can
discipline to work that's my dad how
brutal he was i had a friend of mine he
would come over two guys would come over
to our house he'd call both of them
gordo you know what gordon means gordon
is like
one of them
never showed up again the last time he
was in the room with my daddy was 25
he's 43 right now wow because he's
afraid my dad's gonna say hey gordo hey
gordon that's my dad right how he is i
said that you can't talk to people like
though he's fat well you want me to tell
him so he's gone better over the years
he's 79 now he's listening to this year
but he called this guy gordon another
guy he called him gordon george palano
he says hey gordo when are you going to
fix that look at your pants it doesn't
fit when you get my dad would straight
up and by the way my dad
is he the sweetest guy or what he's yeah
the nicest guy you'll meet right most
cerebral smartest yeah like it's almost
like a real life socrates real talk just
a chill guy he's five how tall is he i
i'm six four six five how tall is my dad
what would you say my dad is i think
he's about uh five nine i wanna give him
an inch or two okay so five five seven
but he's just like like this yeah right
you know what george did with it was
that he changed george will make three
million dollars this year at 34 years
old 35 years old right but he changed he
he decided to say maybe this guy's right
you know what i'm saying maybe there's
somebody that's given a feedback so one
day we're having a debate like that and
i say that i think that guy can change
he'll never change that i think that guy
can change patrick i'm telling you he'll
never change you think
everybody is willing to work their asses
off like you're working what do you
think the world is like that guy is not
going to change
he was right half the time i was right
half the time okay meaning there were
guys that i believe but i bank on
believing people can change the story in
my life is i believe people can change
right
there's a part of it where you wonder
it's so deep rooted to the core
that
you know
i mean
nike contract
you know what i mean the only ufc fight
that's ever been canceled was 151 with
dan henderson yeah you know this it's
the only one ever that you know dana's
like
and he second chance third chance four
chance all of this stuff
um
you're talking about jon jones here
right now yeah jon jones was going to
fight the what was the fight it was
another fight in that understanding
johnson anthony johnson and he got her
and then you know test deposit right
yeah so all of these things and the last
minute dana doesn't want to cancel a
fight are you freaking kidding me who
the hell wants to cancel a fight it's
it's a bad look on the sport right you
have to refund cancellations all this
[ __ ] media is going to write about
it they're struggling they're going out
of business nobody's watching them
anymore who the hell wants to answer all
these questions right
um
so yeah i i i wonder who's in his ear
well danny even said david said it's it
you know it's impossible for me to bet
on jon jones on a weekend in vegas
it's impossible for me to bet on jon
jones do you know how do you know how
tough that is for
for you for uh for a guy who has given
people not just him he's given people so
many seconds he's like jimmy johnson
jimmy johnson like to go get people who
got arrested yeah who did that was his
motto right even
bill belichick is good at doing that he
did that with a few different guys
this isn't an industry where you're
pulling guys out of cornell totally
right
but listen neither is listen michael
what did you talk about miami was you're
going to be any hurricane that's what i
mean no no no no no there's a place in
this world for pirates though bro you
know what i'm saying
i get i get there is there's a place for
pirates but i think when
john sense i'll change i think he wants
to that's the difference like you see
john's interview and he says i i'm going
to change i want to change
i think he wants to
then there is somebody else in the ear
who is that is the right person in the
ear is the person willing to listen to
the person in the air but bro let me
give you a different perspective i i
guarantee i guarantee you well here's my
question and
i'm going to open it up for you
hypothetically i don't know jon jones
anywhere near where you guys everyone
here has said that he's the number one
guy of all time everyone
why would he change
maybe what is keeping him freaking mad
and doing that
is what
is the reason that he's number one i i
actually tell you that i can't believe
it like tiger woods when tiger woods
changed he wasn't tiger him
why would he change that's a literal
great point yeah they happen from uh
once again but that's not the point
though listen
give it to great great great example
but the tiger woods his example was 16
porn stars guys this this guy and he was
winning masters yeah no no but that's
not the point though the point that
tiger gets credit on what he said which
is not everybody can do this
we have a guy that i work with jose
gaiton okay
we're sitting in my office one time i'm
interviewing this guy who wants to work
with us jose sitting over here i'm
sitting over here we're in north church
california which is the earthquake
capital of the world right
sit and talk so so johnny tell me about
your background who were you in high
school i'm asking them all these
questions
all of a sudden
massive earthquake is going in the
middle of the interview
glass is going like this shit's falling
down no joke
this guy i look to the right to look at
the window i look to the left this guy's
running out the window right he's
running out the door he's out he left
the office he went outside
no no not guy the other guy here's jose
oh
so bad what
we should probably leave
what do you think i said yeah he just
goes you know real slow
gets up and starts walking out jose dude
a hurricane could hit a r earthquake
could hit he's still going to be texting
because they're serious
but what i'm saying is like a people who
can balance shit's not going right in
your personal life and you're still
winning tiger could pull that off right
not a lot of people can't do that jon
jones could pull that off not a lot of
people can't do that
but for every story like that you hear
there's a ton of stories that end with a
horror story and this guy's got a family
this guy's got people that love him and
at the end of the day uh i get like even
michael michael was reckless totally
getting michael was reckless but to what
level though
taylor i mean it goes on and on yeah
lawrence taylor that story is not didn't
end well lauren still could have had a
complete different career for himself
how much better credit though the
promise
not the sport life is bigger than sports
though life is bigger than sports yeah
the problem is sometimes these athletes
you know
they have this this dark passenger like
this other side to themselves that
allows them to
rise to the occasion
and and that darkness needs it need the
needs to eat it needs to feed you know
so you have to do dark things in order
to feed it and
sometimes they over indulge in it you
know and it becomes and it takes over
who they are you know but you have to be
able to
uh be able to understand the difference
between the two you have to understand
when it's time to feed the beast yeah
and when it's time not to you know and
and if you
are getting over indulging in and
defeating it then you're out of balance
because it's all it's all it's all
standing such a good point
for example you know jordan peterson
says what
you got to be a monster be a monster be
a monster totally get it uh you know tim
grover in the book relentless i don't
know if you've read it or not he talks
about how all the great ones have a vice
like the internal vice that we deal with
everybody here we all sin in a different
way but ain't nobody in your free if
people went through your search history
or they went through your phone text and
the way you done some conversations
behind closed doors with people we would
all be embarrassed right now with some
of the [ __ ] that we've done right
but then you know we had sammy double
garvano comes and we go to
a restaurant casa d'angelo
i don't know if you know sammy the
bullets yeah
so okay so we go to casa we're sitting
we're having dinner one guy shows up
john mason okay
and he sits in the corner we're having
dinner
sammy looks at john
and he keeps staring at him right and
john
john was a wanted to come he was dying
to come but he didn't want to die to
come you know what i mean like one of
those situations
so he said hey hey sammy hey sammy how
are you he's not even making eye contact
so mario starts joking around telling
sammy sami i just want to let you know
while i was outside john was talking
major smack about your friend
[Laughter]
john's like johnny mays no no i wasn't
he's lying no when john is like
literally like doesn't realize that
mario and samuel are playing a joke on
this guy sure okay
but here's the part so
you know sam is capable
that's the part the fact that he can go
to a very very dark side yeah you know
that's like the the part about having a
gun you don't have a gun to use it every
single day just because you have it you
have a gun so the other person says hey
how you doing everything good awesome
great thank you so much for coming to
our liquor store now get the hell out of
here right yeah i'm capable i think john
we all know you're capable but doug just
like you know what i mean because
this thing is
look you know if you're his agent you're
his manager you're right well you know
this part of darkness that's part of
this how big of a contract with that
nike contract that meant for john
i mean he would he would have jumped
into a different stratosphere when it
comes to who he was yeah that's a 100
million dollar contract yeah yeah it's
going to be a massive contract you're
set right well i just didn't want to do
it you know so those are those are the
things that for me i i you know you win
in life and we typically forget who gave
us that one council or who was there in
that moment that tell us to do this and
to do that and we were about to screw up
where you make that additional phone
call you know what i mean you make that
phone call to somebody you gotta if you
were to make a list of names of people
that impacted your life you'd probably
come up with 20 30 40 names and say at
this point in my life i was 17 this
person said this at 18 my wrestling
coach said this at 19 a bartender i was
working with the boss said this at 19
and a half my mom said this at 20 and a
half the girl that left me said this
you know you got it yeah so but i think
i think the problem is also is the fact
that you know
we're we're putting this on you know who
does he have around him at the end of
the day
you it has to come from here you know
what i'm saying and i feel
i may sound like he hit me for saying
this but i think five grams of mushrooms
will set
i'll tell you what it'd be a lot better
for his career than five grams of white
stuff that's for sure what do you think
that would actually do for huh because
nobody gets better when they do cocaine
i'm gonna tell you this other than dewey
cox
what would the mushrooms do if he did if
he did the toad which is five meow dmt
not the regular stuff that people do
with the you know the
the other you know um
that right there would would show him
something you know because it's um
it's a totally different experience but
at the same time
you uh
you're almost reborn at that moment you
know it's a medicine that just
completely just changes everything that
you even know as as reality and even
yourself so i think he needs something
powerful like that because what he's
searching for he may not even know
anymore you know he just may be feeling
that something is is not right and he's
trying to chase it so they call it
chasing the dragon and you never catch
it never catch it so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you